all right nevada governor steve sisolac
is in las vegas right now getting a
sneak peek of the solar energy project
over at catholic charities of southern
nevada 8 news now reporter victoria saha
joins us live to tell us how this
multi-million dollar project
can help the non-profit serve even more
people victoria
hey hector this is just part one of the
15 million dollar solar panel project on
the seven
acre property here at catholic charities
the organization serves about 3 000
people a day on its campus
that includes housing and meals to
assist that many people it takes a lot
of electricity which is in use
24 7. to offset the majority of those
costs the non-profit set up solar panels
on the roof the multi-million dollar
project is funded by grants
once this is complete they hope this
will allow them to serve
more people in need get a facility like
this a nonprofit
once you get the capital expense out of
the way you're going to save a lot of
money on your utility bills and
these non-profits provide such an
invaluable service our community
taking care like i say our most
vulnerable if we can save them money on
the utility bills it's going to help
everybody a long way
governor sysalek also toured the rest of
the campus where other solar panels will
be installed
so far only one rooftop is complete with
the solar panels
the rest of the campus will be completed
within the next couple of months
reporting from the catholic charities
victoria saha 8 news now